Eli Lilly is now capping the cost of
insulin at 35 this is another tangible
victory that took place under the Biden
Administration this is something that
Joe Biden has been talking about this is
something that Bernie Sanders has been
talking about this is a really great
thing now I know many of you if you're
going to say David this isn't how
economics Works they're capping the cost
to the consumer but someone else is
going to pay for this thing well you
know what that may be the case but it
doesn't have to be that way many of the
same drugs that are cheap in other
countries are sold for more in the U.S
simply because they can and the retail
cost of the drug can be very high
the cost to the consumer can be low and
the difference is paid for by insurance
or subsidized by taxpayers but with a
lot of these drugs we know they aren't
that expensive